hello and thank you for joining our
panel today to learn more about computer
vision at amazon
my name is lindsay weil and i am an
academics program manager
so you're going to hear from me for a
little bit today and then i'm going to
pass it over to the individuals you
actually want to hear from so we have
srinath sridhar
who's an amazon visiting academic and an
assistant professor at brown university
we also have the opportunity to hear
from thomas brocks an
amazon scholar and professor at the
university of freiburg
and last but not least we have zoentu an
amazon scholar and professor at uc san
diego
before i turn it over to these wonderful
academics i'm going to be sharing a
little bit
about some of our team's programs at
amazon and additional opportunities for
academics at all stages to collaborate
with amazon in different capacities
as mentioned two of the individuals on
our panel today are amazon scholars
the amazon scholar program launched in
2018.
our scholars are senior level academics
from around the globe working on
world-class research problems in an
industry
industry context at amazon scholars join
amazon in part-time capacities without
leaving their academic institutions
the scholars program currently has
academics from over
50 universities from across the globe
for more information about the amazon
scholars program
please visit amazon.science scholars
additionally i mentioned that srinagar
street har is an amazon visiting
academic
amazon visiting academics or aba is
amazon science's newest
academic collaboration the visiting
academics program
is a complement to the scholars program
in that it allows academics to work at
amazon in a part-time capacity
without leaving their university while
the scholars program
caters to luminaries in different
science fields
visiting academics is a program for
pre-tenure to newly tenured academics
with professorial affiliations
at universities around the globe please
visit our website to learn more at
amazon.com visiting academics
amazon is also really lucky to work with
academics through our graduate
internship program
amazon hires phd and master students who
can go beyond the coding of engineers
and dive deep into research
investigations as scientists
the majority of our technical
internships take place in the summer and
last between 12 to 16 weeks
international and domestic candidates
are eligible to apply and the 2022
applications begin in september
those three programs are just a piece of
what we're offering from an academic
collaboration standpoint
there are many additional ways for
academics to engage with amazon through
different funding mechanisms and
training resources
please screenshot this slide and visit
the associated website to learn more
about all of these different
opportunities
right thanks lindsay and hello everyone
as lindsay mentioned my name is
srinath i am an assistant professor of
computer science at brown university
i also spend part of my time as an
amazon visiting academic
and my primary area of research is in 3d
computer vision and machine learning
with particular emphasis
on robotics problems and i'm going to
be talking a little bit about high-level
information about some of the robotics
work that we do here at amazon
so robotics uh is deployed widely across
different
areas within amazon uh some of you might
have seen some of these
uh in the in the popular press an
example is primar which is basically the
drone based
aerial robotics part of amazon where the
idea is to deliver packages
at your doorstep robots are also widely
deployed across different
areas of amazon and in particular i'm
part of the robotics and ai division
where we are really interested in
developing and deploying robotics and ai
solutions
to practical problems in amazon
fulfillment centers
so what is a fulfillment center well
fulfillment centers are essentially
amazon warehouses uh which deal with the
logistics
of making sure that an order that you
place on amazon
is uh delivered from vendors sorted
packaged and sent so that you would
receive it on time
so as you can imagine it represents a
very important part of what we do here
at amazon
and it turns out that robotics is quite
useful
in many practical problems within these
fulfillment centers
one of the problems that that occurs
quite often within fulfillment centers
is the task of picking an object from
one part of the fulfillment center and
placing it on another part
so here's a video of
this is a video of one of our robots
picking an object from
one conveyor and placing it on another
conveyor
now these could be pre-packaged objects
or packages that you see here
or they could be unpackaged items but
this process of
picking items and packages from one
conveyor or one part of the
fulfillment center and placing it in
another part occurs quite often within
amazon fulfillment centers and this this
problem in robotics is often referred to
as the pick and place problem so picking
an object from one point and placing it
on another point
and it represents uh a wide variety of
challenges right so this is a problem
that
that is actively researched in the
academic community
and has practical applications um at
amazon as well
so i'm going to give a high level
glimpse of some of the technical
challenges
that are involved in this pick and place
problem and just
overview of some of the problems that we
work here at amazon
and i'm focusing here on mostly on
computer vision challenges because that
is my primary area of interest but of
course there are
other challenges as well in terms of
control and planning
so some of the problems that we deal
with are with items
which could look very similar and often
occur in
in large amounts of clutter and lots of
items so we need to kind of
develop computer vision tools that are
able to separate out these items
using cameras that are located within
fulfillment centers
we also have to deal with a wide range
of items
we're not talking about tens of items
but we're talking more like hundreds of
thousands of
different items that are found in the
amazon catalog
and of course from a computer vision
algorithm perspective
we're really interested in developing
algorithms that
can tell us where to pick these objects
so generation of pic points within
objects
and how to process sensor information
for instance from
color cameras or from depth cameras so
that we can
segment out these objects and separate
them package them and send it off to our
customers
so there's a lot of really interesting
research questions
and unsolved research questions that we
need to address in order to
solve this problem of fulfilling
customer orders
at amazon.com
now what i've talked about so far is
just a very high level overview of
some of the problems that me and my
colleagues here work at amazon
and in the last minute or so i'm going
to spend some time talking about how
being both at brown university and at
amazon
has been very synergistic in terms of
the benefits and the
ideas and the problems that we solve in
both of these
both of these places so i i strongly
believe that
uh if we are really interested in
deploying robots at scale
um in the real world amazon is the place
to do robotics research uh because of
two reasons
uh the first is that you know we can
take the latest or we can
develop the latest academic advancements
and apply it to unstructured settings
like what you would find in a
fulfillment center an image of which is
shown here and the second reason is that
we're operating at amazon scale right so
we're not operating
in a very structured lab setting with a
few tons of items
but we are operating with hundreds of
thousands of different kinds of items
so the kinds of research questions that
these unstructured and amazon scale
settings pose
really intellectually curious and
important problems robotics problems and
computer vision problems to solve
the second reason of course is just like
we do in academia
we set ambitious goals within amazon a
good example of this again is the pick
and place problem
where it's not enough for us to
correctly pick and place 90
of the objects we have to do much better
than that because if we do 90
it means that we miss 10 percentage of
packages of customers and that's just
unacceptable
and finally being at a university and
amazon provides mutually beneficial
perspectives so
the theory theoretical problems that we
think about in academia
find practical applications within
amazon and some of the problems
practical problems in amazon fulfillment
centers lead to new theoretical
perspectives in academia
so personally i have found it very
useful to kind of
have have a feed on both both these
places
so with that i'd like to thank the
opportunity for making this short
presentation
uh and i'd be happy to answer any
questions later in the panel
thank you rox i'm
an amazon scholar who joined the the
tubing and lablet
uh about one year ago
um so uh here you see the
the whole team um so you see it consists
of three scholars and um four full-time
researchers
and um about the concept of uh lablets
and amazon there's also a shanghai
lablet and a palo alto lablet
and the idea of these lablets in amazon
is to follow a longer term research
agenda
that is not directly bound to a to a
product or a service but
to act at a meta level for the whole
company
and that means that you can actually
have science impact on one hand but also
reaching many customers if
one of your ideas is successful and also
applies to to customer problems
so the um the chipping and lablet
specializes on
causal representation learning um so
when i was
first confronted with the term of
causality then it also sounded a bit
abstract to me
um and i think that happens to a couple
of people
but on the other hand causality is
actually pretty natural for scientists
because
in science we try to find uh the the
causal principles in nature
uh or in our technology so it's not
sufficient that you find a correlation
in some data but you actually want to
figure out that it's really a causal
relationship
and that is not always easy yeah so for
example in this
covet city we sometimes
relations but um they were not not
actually caused by something that we
thought would be the cause and um
the hypothesis here in in the tubing and
lablet is also that
this is a problem partially in in
current machine learning because it's
based on statistical learning um
identically and independently
data so each sample is actually it's
independent sample and the samples don't
have anything
which means that you actually cannot do
real good
causal uh representation learning and we
believe that
this statistical purely statistical
learning is also responsible for many
issues
in practice so for example we see that
we have lacking robustness of methods or
small changes
in the data can certainly expected
effects
also like interpretability of our
results
so we cannot exactly tell in all the
cases why something failed or why
something worked
and also the generalization although
it's much better than what we had
10 or 20 years ago is still not as
perfect as we would expect and as we
know from nature for example
and we also see that we require rather
huge data sets
to be really successful on some tasks
and
it requires artificial annotation and
all this is very different from
the learning that we find in nature so
there we learn actually from
non-iid data so for example videos so
the data is
related to each other and we also learn
from natural supervisory signals
so not from artificial annotation
but for humans it's a bit special
because we also have language so we can
actually learn from our parents via
language
but um that's not the main signal that
is driving the
very young babies yeah so um that means
the the natural supervisory signals uh
are very important and they are
underestimated maybe in
um in in current machine learning and
also we are using a lot of intervention
so for example young children
at a certain age they always drop
certain things to actually learn
yeah what is the effect of
that something is heavy when does it
fall and when does it not fall
and that's actually some intervention
that allows them to do causal learning
yeah so they
they find that if they move it away from
the table so it has no support anymore
then the thing will drop yeah so
they find out the cause of something
dropping
and and these are the principles that we
want to pick up and also bring into
machine learning
and one example maybe that is quite
successful and that is used by the
community quite a lot
is um the data augmentation which is
currently the most powerful tool
probably for robustness
and it can actually be derived from
causal principles namely the principle
of invariance and also the principle of
intervention that you're actually taking
one sample and you're
you're changing the sample in a certain
way um
and it's also based on non-iid subsets
because you actually take one sample and
you're modifying it so all the samples
within this patch are
um are dependent on each other
so that's the motivation why this causal
representation learning um
it should be actually quite promising
but we should also say that the
imagenet moment of course representation
learning has not happened yet
um at least not in computer vision
um and that's a bit our job to to make
progress here
um causality has already been
successfully applied on on simpler
data especially on simple time series
data but also tabular data
so there you can have for example good
effects on interpretability
and also on higher robustness
and the questions that we that we are
working on is can we extend this to
higher dimensional vision data so for
example videos
and vision is particularly hard because
the current process that we're using is
actually anti-causal and we have this
very high dimensional data which
makes the schemes that we that we
typically know
um not applicable and then
the question is also how can we
implement interventions so i already
told about
data augmentation as a very simple one
but if you want to generalize this
to more naturalistic settings um
yeah some some paths go via generative
models
um you can also use simulations or
embodied learning via robotics
these are all ways on how you could use
also interventions
and then the question is will causal
learning really yield this
expected robustness and generalization
that i motivated before
and how will this affect products and
services in amazon
and not only in amazon also maybe in
other companies and other
domains and we are still looking for a
few scientists
so if you feel you're a top scientist
then you can also
apply directly with
our manager and the email you find here
so
just send them your cv and then it will
be considered
so thank you very much
hello everyone my name is john 2 i'm an
amazon scholar
with the amazon aws computer vision
science team
today i'll be presenting two cvpr
2021 papers along the line
of self-supervised and semi-supervised
learning
the availability of large-scale data
sets is one
of the driving forces for the
advancement of
the recent deep learning and computer
vision field
however obtaining
large scale data sets is both expensive
and time-consuming
self-supervised learning is an emerging
technique that
can help alleviate the burden of
requiring
fully supervised data in particular for
pre-training the first work
is called exponential moving average
normalization for
self-supervised and semi-supervised
learning
by jaway thai avinash
ravi chandra subraj su maji
charles focus zowan ii and stefano soato
self supervised learning can be
typically understood
under a student teacher framework given
image
two views are typically being generated
one goes through a student model
the other one goes to a teacher model
then a consistent loss is being computed
in the spread to hold closure the two
views of the same image
while pushing away the views of
different images
batch normalization is a standard
technique
used in training deep models
however in the context of
self-supervised learning
batch normalization has some problems
if used directly one is called
cross sample dependency there's
information leakage
the second is called the model mismatch
because the way
the student model and teacher model
learned are different from how batch
normalization is computed
because of that
alternative approaches have been used
in this work called the exponential
moving average
we provide an alternative
in standard batch normalization a sample
is being normalized
using the mean and the variance computed
for each individual batch
in the year my algorithm
just each sample is also being
normalized however
the mean and the variance are computed
and updated
under exponential moving average
principle
as well
this is the pseudo code above here is
standard
explosion moving average update for the
teacher model
down below is the em m
eman algorithm that updates
the batch normalization statistics
under exemption moving average principle
as well
that makes updating the teacher model
and the computing the statistics
consistent eman has been used
in self-supervised learning and
semi-supervised learning
there's a consistent improvement so in
conclusion
exposure moving average normalization is
a simple design
that reduce the issue of cross-sample
dependency
and the parameter mismatched in multiple
self-supervised and semi-supplied
learning frameworks
eman makes consistent improvement on
multiple
self-supervised and semi-survived firm
with good generalization
the second award is called humble
teachers
teach better students for assembly
supervised objective action
by ihee tan wae fun chan yi jin law
and yu ting zhang so in this work
there's one standard supervised learning
branch
and also there's an unsupervised
learning branch utilizing
unlabeled data is a combined loss
during training so in
unsupervised learning branch there's a
student model taking strongly
augmented image and also the teacher
model takes ensemble
based on weekly augment data
then the teacher model will generate
soft label
to train the student model
the teacher model is being updated using
exponential moving average
algorithm as well
this humble teacher model has been
applied
in semi-supervised learning for update
detection and
obtain obtain consistent improvement
so in conclusion this hunger teacher
model for
semi-survived object detection observes
good performance
the the hunger teacher model generates
soft pseudo labels when guiding the
steel model
and overall this approach obtains
improve results
thank you
thank you zoen thomas and srinath we're
going to move to a quick q a
and it's going to be great to hear from
you on a question that we often get at
conferences
which is what learnings or experiences
at
amazon have you taken back with you and
applied at your university or do you
hope to apply in the future
so srinath let's have you take this one
first
sure that's that's a good question
lindsay i've thought about this a little
bit as well and and i think to me
uh what surprised me the most pleasantly
surprised me the most
at amazon was this culture of working
backwards relentlessly from the goal
and i think that's very useful also in
research and academic research because
that allows you not just to focus on the
high level problems but also
think through the details of the
solution that you might propose for a
research question
so this is certainly something that i
would be interested in uh
taking into my research group in
academia
thank you yeah maybe i can add to that
so
um so typically when you stay in
academia then you often work at
as academic problems and um things
work much better than they would
actually do in reality
and um yeah working at amazon with
all these different customers and
service teams
uh you actually get confronted with with
reality and you get the reality check
for all the methods that
tend to be perfect already but are
actually far from being perfect in
reality and then you have to find the
tweaks
and um yeah that makes you a little bit
more humble and also in academia and i
can also give that back to
to the students also master students who
think that
deep learning solves everything and i
can tell them that
that's not true
i also i'll be happy to add to that a
little bit kind of happily surprised to
see
how seamless uh it is in terms of the
integration between
academics and also industry
in recent deep learning in computer
division uh it's
it's uh natural but also to some degree
as a surprise
that you you need to do research
industry
almost like students or professors at
university you have to keep up
everything we're reading papers
constantly to make
a better product uh and that's i think
it's a very kind of a pleasant
experience because you don't need to
so okay so i'm gonna focus on the fully
the engineering side but the endurance a
lot of the engineering tricks cannot be
translated into
really advanced technology so you really
need to have integration
between the two in a seamless way
thank you all so much for those answers
i really like the emphasis on working
backwards and application and
integration i think those are great
themes to take away from today
and thank you again for your amazing
presentations that was just wonderful
if you have any questions our team would
be
more than happy to welcome the
opportunity to connect so
please reach out at academics interest
amazon.com with any questions and please
stay in touch with
us through any of the platforms that
we've mentioned today especially
amazon.science
which is a research site that features
our customer obsessed research
thank you so much for attending and
thank you again to our wonderful
panelists
thank you